[Laughter]
a lot from just general crew members the
twilight cast spent almost five years of
their lives filming as your favorite
vampires werewolves and humans it's only
natural that they'd want some type of
memorabilia to remember their time with
the box office phenomena but stealing
props from a set comes with a big risk
stealing
how about borrowing ready to find out
which actors were successful and who was
put in the hot seat for their
shenanigans
out of the entire cast robert pattinson
was probably one of the actors who had
the most free reign over which props he
could take a swipe at apparently rob
stole a lot of things from seth but he
wasn't interested in the cullen emblem
or edward's wedding ring what he wanted
was his character's underwear throughout
the five films he became obsessed with
them and stole them on multiple
occasions i've heard rumors of a certain
man
named rob's doing some under underpants
they have the best underwear and i have
no idea where they get it from i use it
every day kristen stewart wasn't too
impressed with his revelation underwear
that's so weird well kristen
people have different tastes
while rob went for a more unique
approach to prop stealing kristin stuck
with what was most important to her
character and took some items that she
knew she'd cherish for the rest of her
life what did you take i took my rings
she managed to get her hands on not one
but three of bella's rings throughout
the films i took the rings i have the
engagement ring the moon ring and the
wedding ring i didn't steal it i mean
they knew they knew i took it while the
moon ring reminds her of director
catherine hardwick and the other two of
bella all three are very significant in
her life they are really truly quite
important to me it's amazing that she
was able to walk away with the
engagement ring considering how much
work went into it including
consultations with stephanie meyer
herself so what we ended up doing is
having a conversation with stephanie
meyer and this is the final result
but kristin didn't just stop at the
rings she helped one of her fellow
co-stars get her hands on the prop she
had been vying for while filming the
first twilight movie nikki reed
absolutely loved the cleats that rosalie
wore during the twilight baseball scene
but she was just a little too nervous
about taking them and although kristin
kept pushing saying this is not a big
deal you can just have your shoes
nikki just couldn't do it you don't
understand what you're doing kristin
took them for me because i just could
never take anything from the set because
i'm such a rule follower regardless she
didn't just swipe them for her she made
it a huge surprise the two had a thing
going where they would buy each other
converse shoes but one day kristen put
the cleats in the shoebox
instead ashley greene was obsessed with
alice's wardrobe and who can blame her
the cullens all had fashion sense but
alice was on a whole other level ashley
was especially drawn to her undercover
look in italy while filming new moon
ashley has been very open about the
amount of borrowing she's done oh really
while what she wanted was the stunning
michael kors coat she wore she had to
settle for stealing the ray-ban
sunglasses she wore instead she's still
in disbelief that she didn't get to keep
the coat it's just so crazy that i
didn't end up getting it on the bright
side she still has the glasses to
remember the jacket by who wouldn't want
to make a scene
peter faccinelli followed in kristin's
footsteps but wasn't successful at first
when new moon wrapped he knew he had to
find a way to keep the extremely cool
custom cullen ring he got to wear but he
got caught they called me and asked for
it back i was like i don't know where it
is they were like we need it for the
next movie but peter was persistent and
safe to say in the end he was successful
with his prop stealing when we did
breaking dawn part two it might have or
it might not have been left on my finger
when i got home don't worry peter no one
has to know
kellen lutz claims he wasn't all that
into the whole prop stealing situation
and instead kept the memories from the
film close to heart but there was one
prop he walked away with from the first
film just like his on-screen wife he
became quite attached to the vampire
baseball scene and asked the producers
if he could take the hat emmet war okay
so he didn't exactly steal the prop but
he had the guts to ask to take one and
that is just as scary i tried to steal
mackenzie foy but i wasn't allowed while
these cast members will have something
to remember their time on twilight by
others like taylor lautner who turned
down jacob's wig i should have kept that
thing and elizabeth reeser who just
never had the opportunity to take
anything have major regrets i thought
they would call me later and offer me
something and they never did sometimes
stealing that prop is worth the risk
just ask nikki what twilight prop would
you want to take home with you let us
know in the comment section below thanks
for watching
you